i'm going to talk about the 10 benefits
of something called
l-arginine this is an amino acid
l-arginine has the ability to release
through its bio chemical breakdown
something called nitric oxide which is
very different than nitrous oxide which
is laughing gas when you go to the
dentist
nitric oxide and it only lasts a few
seconds
but this right here has the ability to
relax
your arteries the smooth muscle and the
arteries which is going to
lower your blood pressure it's going to
lower stress
it decreases free radicals so it's like
a
very powerful antioxidant it decreases
ldl cholesterol oxidation it's an
anticoagulant
it helps erectile dysfunction
it helps your immune system it increases
blood flow through your brain
as well as through the lung that's why
you breathe better it also helps relax
sphincters which are smooth muscle
valves
helping things like hemorrhoids for
example and it has the ability to
increase growth hormone which is
anti-aging
fat burning helps muscle strength
build muscle etc now if you think about
it our heart works incredibly hard
contracting relaxing all day all night
you don't have to think about it it's
all automatic
every year your heart beats 39
million times i mean that's a tremendous
amount of work that your heart has to
perform and so when your
arteries relax you not only
take the stress off the arteries but you
also
increase blood flow into the heart
muscle itself preventing things like
angina what i would recommend taking if
you were going to take this is
three grams two times a day
you'd want to take that on an empty
stomach now there's something else that
you may want to add to that
is either the consumption of beets
or you can take beets in a powder
because beets are very high in nitrates
and that can also activate nitric oxide
and beets are also high in boron which
has other great benefits
now here are the cons of l-arginine if
you have
herpes already in your body whether it's
herpes simplex like a cold sore
or you have herpes zoster as in the
virus behind shingles
if you take too much l-arginine that can
reactivate
these viruses and bring them out so
those are the cons so there's quite a
few benefits but there's some drawbacks
as well
all right well thank you for watching
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help